a lot of the time with reality TV stuff
they will go to modeling agencies it
makes sense because they want people
that are good looking but they also want
people that are comfortable on camera a
lot of people ask questions about how
scripted are these reality TV shows
because there's always conspiracies
about these people were plants they were
put in there to be together or to do
whatever these people especially in
stuff like love Island six weeks ago
they were hairdressers you're dealing
with a girl who was a normal person a
few weeks ago so I make it to basically
the World Cup final of being a party boy
like it's this brand new TV show six
weeks and while I'm there there's no
phone no TVs no calls no nothing it's
just you and 13 other people and while I
was there I was around people who
genuinely were the hyper extroverted
super energetic person that I thought I
was and because I'd no longer had any
distractions it gave me a fatal dose of
contrast and I got to see the person
that I thought I was who was all of them
compared with the person that I actually
was that was me it did teach me that
there was some sort of Discord going on
in my life there was friction something
wasn't in in congruence here and I
needed to work out what was going on